nous
m
[Musique]
rapidement tout l'été au pays des jeunes
a dit vraiment on vient de bart debie
avec le grand yaka les feux je vous dis
pas à vous amuser
allez vite retrouver le grand gâteau
vous demande où est de trouver cbi je
ferai bien une partie vous ne peut pas
jouer tout seul
capcom cas
amy dtt c'est à quel sujet il ya an par
une partie billes avec moi j'vois ou pis
moi ah non je ne veux pas fâcher ma robe
à mon cas ça te prend pas une partie de
beach est d'abord un show n'est pas le
moment c'est que j'avais chez qui marie
abadie mois au coutelas le plus beau
collier du grand yaka disparu collier
splendide je le cherche partout autant
posséder une bible encore non non non
non qui qu il faut que je retrouve ce
que le shisha la personne de vos vies
avec moi on m'a oublié melchior ils
seront sûrement d'accord je vais lui en
parler
belga baker
le bo la haye allait fermer phase permet
pour cause de fermeture croit alors
c'est pas de chance même temps n'est pas
fini harper vous ré demain verra monter
mais b tu me l'as titus et regarde j'ai
trouvé débit tu vas jouer avec moi mais
là elle entreprendra biya mois et le
solde à montpellier pour ce baby vient
en aide à menthe ou t'es pas vous ici
alors on vous si tu daignes ruby je te
tais toi ou au congo dans la ville et
ont commencé voilà avoue grand hyatt à 1
mondiaux et était elle est partie il a
été trop fort et dégueulasse trop fort
c'est parce que je suis le plus fort et
elle est encore parti on voit comment
femmes de paris et les bus seront perdus
je suis le plus fort c'est moi le plus
peur mais bien plus loin que les tiennes
j'ai cherché dans tous les coins le
collier du grand jacques à est
introuvable qu'elle fait
cachés chez vous ou par exemple une
perle une des pires halle du collier du
grand yaka
j'ai bien une perle n'est ce pas je ne
me trompe pas c'est une perte ras puis
de chevaux de perles pas une troisième
faire encore des perles
mais doug et rennes chez les pupilles
titus aller de l'avant le ciel
enfin bull alors c'est trop loin son
père deux tonnes et la dernière est
partie j'ai perdu toute ma vie mais je
me suis bien amusé et getti d'espérer
j'ai reconstitué le collier du craj ak
je vais le lui apporter
vous aviez des coteaux de gagner la
partie
les b sera à moi on a beaucoup de
bêtises je n'ai qu'une parole tu seras
récompensé
botia voilà ce que j'arrive à yatta
charlie alors qu'est-ce que tu
m'apportes cela allait me [ __ ] que six
écrans yaka vous vouliez le m
aujourd'hui donne à titus il a gagné un
parti de lui je suis très content j'ai
perdu mais je les subis la vision ma
mois ont pris le relais des et après
après c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]